bonjour à vous que révèle la large
victoire de gabriel boric candidat de
gauche à l'élection présidentielle au
chili et bonjour et je pense que c'est
un moment vraiment important de
l'histoire moderne du pays
ça également ça signifie
le commencement de la fin de la
dictature de pinochet
parce que parallèlement à l'élection de
démo reach on a un processus de avec une
nouvelle constitution qui est en train
d'être écrite dans les pays et donc ça
fait 2-2 processus que parallèle qui
vont avoir lieu et
maintenant dans le pays et qu'est ce qui
a permis à gabriel bourriche de faire la
différence lors de ces scrutins
moi je pense que c'est un travail de
fond
boric fait partie d'une génération qui
étaient là
dans la rue il ya disons quand il ya eu
lieu les premières manifestations des
étudiants au chili ensuite il a fait il
a été président de la fédération des
étudiants de l'université du chili donc
c'est pas quelqu'un de nouveau même s'il
est très très jeune c'est à quelqu'un de
nouveau dans la politique mais j'avais
présente un nouveau visage et une
nouvelle manière de faire de la
politique et l influence du parti
communiste présent dans la coalition de
gauche laquelle appartient gabriel boric
que faisant dire à ce niveau ouais
écoutez moi je pense que ça c'est
les jeux crois que c'était le prévient
gouvernement de madame bachelet donc il
ya déjà quelques années où les partis
communistes a eu des ministres et les
pays n'a pas été submergée dans les
causes ni rien du tout donc pour moi les
partis communistes c'est une force
politique historique du chili qui a tout
à fait sa place dans les large éventail
de reach souhaite mettre en place
et finalement qu'est-ce que sa victoire
révèle aujourd'hui sur la situation au
chili
bat le chili c'est un pays
extraordinaire à plusieurs points de vue
et il l'a été
il ya 40 ans
focalisés par les cieux du monde entier
avec l'expérience de salvador allende
qui est arrivé au pouvoir qui était un
socialiste
parle également l'avoir électorale
ensuite nous avons traversé 17 ans d'une
dictature sanguinaire et qui laisse les
blessures ouvertes malgré les 30 années
de transition
après la chute du général pinochet et
maintenant je crois qu'il ya un gain
énorme espoir dans le pays la campagne
des tories tu as été absolument
phénoménale jamais un président j
ayant perdu le
les premières tours où avait été lue au
deuxième quelles vont être ses priorités
et les difficultés aussi que gabriel
boric pourrait rencontrer dans les
semaines à venir
je crois qu'il sera face à des défis
colossaux
il a dit hier dans son discours
il ya des priorités qui sont qui sont
celles que la rue a mis en place avec
les référendums et élections
des constituants pour rédiger une
nouvelle constitution et c'est tout
aussi des défis
économiques politiques relance de
l'économie mais il a mis l'accent sur
l'art et distribution de de la richesse
le chili est un pays riche où il ya une
très infime partie de duffy dit kiki et
bénéficie de ses richesses
merci beaucoup à vous et orgue et aurait
à la nage que vous êtes un fondateur du
bloc flanc france chez mission